is considered one of the most popular
politicians in iraq
his party was the biggest winner in
october's election with 73 of 329 seats
but after months of no party being able
to form a government
sadda announced he was considering
stepping down
three days later his party followed
iraq does not need the formation of a
government but an effective government
whose majority serves its people returns
its glory and obedience to god so let
our beloved cedric's block members write
their resignations from parliament
analysts say the move is confusing
al-sadr is a staunch opponent of iranian
influence in iraqi politics yet the
supreme court rules the next party with
the highest votes will gain the seats
and that party is closely allied with
iran this means
more seats to be gained by the
state of law uh group which is headed by
mr nuril maliki
by groups that are affiliated with the
popular mobilization forces so it's
going to strengthen the hand of this
coalition which is a pro-iran coalition
october's general election had been
pushed forward after large protests
shook the country
two years earlier crowds amassed in
baghdad's terrorist square as people
demanded jobs better services and an end
to state corruption
they swelled and spread south leading to
the resignation of prime minister adel
abdul mahdi by may
tens of thousands of supporters of
al-sadr also turned out in a show of
political clout the media websites which
are affiliated with the sad risks have
already started to call for protest uh i
mean so there is a fear that we might go
back to the kind of violence that was
present in 2019
al-sadr had failed to jockey for a
majority coalition in parliament
but many now question whether he will
influence his supporters to mount
political pressure from the streets
laura bader manly al jazeera